them receive citations. And the biggest mistake that holds them back is that they blindly follow the rulebooks of academic writing style. But the real tragedy is not that they don’t get citations; it’s that their research doesn’t impact all the lives that it was destined to. Imagine if Watson & Crick’s discovery of the structure of DNA had never been published; there would be less understanding of genetic disease, no CRISPR, and no personalized medicine. Fortunately, Watson and Crick were good writers, and their use of academic style is one of the reasons why their discovery had such a great impact on the scientific community. So today we’re going to follow in their footsteps by looking at three tips for academic writing style that have been scientifically proven to increase the likelihood that your research will get published in high impact journals and cited by others in your field. Welcome back to Writer Science, the channel where we explore the art and science of professional and academic writing.If you’re new here, my name is William and I’m an English professor based in South Korea, and for the writing tips in this video come from an analysis of over 30,000 articles with high impact ratings – that is, those published in top journals or which received a ton of citations. And the results might surprise you – they certainly surprised me. Now of course, scientific ideas spread because they are valuable. But let me ask you this: If a tree falls in the forest and nobody hears it, does it make a sound? And if you make a discovery and nobody reads about it, does it make an impact? The main reason why so many academic researchers don’t get the attention they deserve is not because their work isn’t valuable; it’s because of the biggest mistake going: they just blindly follow the academic writing rulebooks and never learn how to use academic writing style effectively, and for that reason their ideas are dead in the water. Luckily, the first common mistake to avoid is pretty straightforward: In the propagation of ideas, it’s essential to prioritize the cognitive accessibility of the discourse over the display of the originator's erudition. Got it? Good. Moving on. The second mistake is… According to the rule books, academic writing is supposed to be complex. If it’s too simple, they say, then it will make the ideas seem simple and unimportant, and they’ll never get published in high-impact journals. And it’s actually true that the complexity of your writing has a big effect on whether the research will be accepted for publication, except that it’s in exactly the opposite direction. This study by Oppenheimer took a group of original essays, and then kept the ideas the same but increased the complexity of the language. If the rule books are right, then you would expect that the more complex articles would have higher acceptance rates than the simpler originals. But exactly the opposite is true. The essays with the highest complexity were rated worse than the moderately complex ones, which in turn were rated worse than the simple originals. And this is true across genres. From college admissions essays to research reports, simpler language leads to higher acceptance rates. And to show you why that is, I need you to consider the way ideas spread. If an idea is carried by complex language, then it will never make it off the page and into the mind of the reader. That’s because there’s only so much work that a reader is willing to do to unpack your writing and find your message. On the other hand, when an idea is presented in clear language, it can move easily from the page to the mind of our reader. And when the reader can grasp our idea easily, they’ll be more likely to carry it and pass it on to others in the form of citation. Many academic writers like to dress up their ideas in complex language in order to make themselves appear smart, but this just turns off the reader. So the goal of our writing should not be to make ourselves seem smart; instead, we should write in a way that makes the reader feel smart. Now one thing I have to make clear here is that we’re not talking about dumbing down our ideas. We don’t want to talk to the reader like a fifth grader. What we’re talking about is packaging our ideas in a way that will be easier for the reader to process. But how do we reduce complexity? This is our idea; and this is the DNA of the idea. Except we don't call it DNA; we call it Syntax. Syntax is like the DNA of an idea because it’s code we use to share and replicate ideas. If the code is complex, then there are going to be mutations in the DNA and the idea won’t make it into the mind of the reader. So we need to make sure the code is as simple and straightforward as possible. Here's the same idea presented in two different codes. Which one is easier to understand? It's the second one, of course, because in the DNA of ideas, there are only two elements: content words (like nouns, verbs, and adjectives); and function words (like prepositions and determiners). Each of these codes use the same content words; but one uses way more function words than the other. When a sentence has a lot of these function words, it becomes heavy with all these branches. Academic articles written with fewer articles and fewer prepositions in the introduction get more citations. The fewer function words, the simpler the sentence; and the simpler the sentence, the easier it is for the reader to get our idea and the more likely they will be to share that idea with others, which brings us to the second rule about academic writing style. According to the rule books, academic writing should be formal and impersonal. After all, we’re not talking about literature here; this is science, and science is objective. This objectivity, according to the rule book, should be reflected in the writing style itself. It doesn’t matter who does the research; what matters is the research itself. That’s why so many academic writers choose to use passive sentences and avoid the use of personal pronouns. Pssst... and it’s also why their research fails to pick up publications and citations. To understand why impersonal language doesn’t work in academic writing, take a look at this: It's a Klein bottle, and it represents a mathematical surface that has no edges or orientation - no outside, and no inside. It can be thought of as a higher-dimension analogue to the Mobius strip, but, unlike the Mobius strip, which has only one side and one boundary, the Klein bottle has no boundaries at all. Now compare that description of the Klein bottle with this one, from a popular TED talk. Which presentation are you more likely to remember? The information is the same, but when it’s presented by a researcher who is clearly passionate about the Klein bottle, it’s a lot easier for us to share that interest. People relate to other people, and readers are people, so when there’s a person present in the story, it makes it a lot easier for the reader to connect to the story and receive the ideas. And that connection makes it a lot easier for the writer to persuade the reader that the research is valuable. Now it’s important to note that this doesn't work in every place throughout the entire article. Personal language only helps with citations when they’re in the front matter, which is the introduction and the abstract. By contrast, articles that use personal language in the middle section–the methods and results–actually receive fewer citations. And to understand why that is, we need to consider the purpose of these sections. The purpose of the mid section is to unpack the finer details of the experiment itself. It’s sometimes known as the empirical section. At this point of the report, the reader doesn’t care about the story; instead, readers come to this section to examine the author’s methods and findings. So it makes sense that the most successful authors would use passive and impersonal sentences, which hides the presence of the author and highlight the work itself. On the other hand, the purpose of the front matter–the abstract and introduction–is to motivate our reader, to get them interested in our research. If we introduce this research using impersonal language, then it’s like the Klein bottle; the reader’s not going to care. But like the mad scientist in the TED Talk, the most successful articles use personal language in the abstract and introduction in order to capture the reader’s interest and motivate them to read the rest of the report. But not only can personal language help capture the reader’s interest, it also changes the way the reader perceives you. When you take personal ownership of ideas, it makes you seem more authoritative. If you introduce valuable research with personal language, readers will associate that value with you, making you seem more credible and important. So if your work is any good, then don’t be shy; let the reader know that it’s yours, especially in the front matter. If you follow the lousy rule books and stick with impersonal language, your research will appear lifeless and detached, as though the ideas–your ideas–are just out there floating in the ether. But to understand the third and final tip about academic writing style, I want you to take a look at these two restaurant reviews. Which one seems more appetizing? Many people would agree that the one written in the present tense sounds more convincing. But if the present tense is more convincing, then why do so many academic rule books tell us to write about research using the past tense? A lot of people think that they have to use the past tense to talk about research in the past. Makes sense, right? It's the past tense; research happened in the past. But that's wrong. It's kind of a deeper grammatical point that we don't have to get into here, but the basic message is that tense has nothing to do with time, and there's no rule that says you have to use the past tense to talk about research just because it happened in the past. In fact, there are some really good reasons to use the present tense whenever you talk about your own research. When we divorce tense from time, it becomes really easy to see why authors who write about their research in the present tense receive more citations. Just like the restaurant reviews, the present tense makes research seem more current, relevant, and applicable. The past tense, sounds like old news; it's passé, stale, and forgotten. So when writing about your own research, using the present tense will make it seem more current, more alive, which makes it more likely to get picked up for citation. Yes, the research happened in the past; but if we follow the rulebooks and write about our research using the so-called past tense, then it’s going to seem like old news, so breath life into your research by using the present tense. So I really hope you see that, if your research isn't getting the attention it deserves, it’s really not your fault; it’s the fault of the old academic rule books. But to tell you the truth, if it's citations that you’re looking for, you would actually be better off not writing a research report at all and instead, you need to check out this video right here because it’s going to show you how to write a different kind of academic article that has been shown to get cited way more often and over longer periods of time than the standard IMRaD research report, so be sure to go check it out.